So what have I drawn down here?
So what I've drawn is an MDP and a
particular trajectory through that MDP.
So here are the dots or
states and the little lines
are sort of the actions that you took
to move between those states, and
whatever awards you happen
to pick up along the way.
So I'm in some MDP,
a Markov decision process and
I am moving through states taking
actions and receiving rewards.
And I'm sort of moving through that, and
that's kind of what we've been
thinking about before, right?
This is what the Bellman
equation sort of captures for us.
We're going to be in a state, take
an action, end up in the next state,
maybe getting rewards.
I should accumulate all that and
use that to update my estimate of the
value of being in a particular state.
Right, that all sound familiar?
>> That is a diagram of SAR,
SAR, SAR, SAR, SAR.
>> Right this is SAR, SAR, SAR,
SAR, SAR, SAR, SAR, SAR, SAR,
SAR, forever and ever.
Now we know how this works.
One of us, probably both of us at some
point or another, actually started
explaining the math behind here and
how you would back up values and why.
This is a way to do learning.
But in this space where we have
these temporal abstractions,
we have these options.
We're actually violating everything
that we know about MDPs.
And I think it helps there to draw
a slightly different picture.
So because we have these
temporally abstract options,
we are not having very
simple time steps, right?
So here, kind of implicit in this,
is we're in state,
we take an action, and
then we're in another state.
We're in a state, we take an action,
we're in another state, so on and
so forth.
And how much time passes between
visiting each of these states, Michael?
>> I'm going to call it one time step.
>> One time step,
which I'm going to claim,
you may not agree with this, might as
well be the same thing as 0 time stamps.
In some sense, we treat the actions in
an MDP as if they are instantaneous.
And perhaps, to drag on more of
the computer science analogy,
we treat them as if they are atomic.
>> Okay, I'm along with you for
the atomic idea.
I definitely am not along with you in
the it takes 0 time idea, but I guess,
your time in the sense that there's no,
I don't know, there's no crack in it.
There's no window that
anything else can jump in, and
that's really the idea of atomic,
so I think we agree.
>> Yeah, I think we do agree.
You're basically, we're picking
constants, you want to call it 1,
I want to call it 0.
We can both go with that.
>> But that's like me saying T and
F are the same thing.
0 and 1 are not the same thing.
>> They're the same
thing within a constant.
>> [LAUGH] Not
a multiplicative constant.
>> [LAUGH] Fair enough.
But the point here is that,
in some sense, atomic, instantaneous,
what really is happening here,
I was in a state, I took an action,
I end up in another state.
Nothing else can happen.
We treat that time stamp.
It may be a year, it may be a day,
but whatever it is,
we treat them all as if they're
the same and we're just moving along.
In fact, we talk about time steps.
And implicit, I think, in the way
we've been talking about time steps so
far is that they're all the same length,
whatever they are,
which is why you can call
them 1 as opposed to 7.
It doesn't really matter.
The fact is that I take this,
there's an atomic action taken,
I end up somewhere else.
Nothing else happens in the middle.
I can reason about everything.
By contrast,
once we have these options, I mean,
think about this picture up here.
Think about the upper northeast room.
If I'm in this little pink state here,
I just entered into the room, I'm
going to get from here, the east door,
to the south door in some
amount of time, right.
It's going to be made
up of atomic actions,
because all I really have is up,
down, left and right.
And I don't know how long
that's going to take.
Let's say it takes 50 time steps,
it doesn't really matter.
It's going to take the same
number of time steps.
But if I'm in this little space
down here near the bottom,
already near the door,
that's going to take fewer time steps.
So what I'm actually seeing,
with respect to the underlying MDP,
is I start in some state.
I take one of these options,
some amount of time passes,
often more than the single time step,
and then I end up in another state.
And then I take another option, end up
in another state, take another option,
I end up in another state,
and so on and so forth.
And the amount of time that I spend in
each option is variable, potentially.
And is not necessarily the same as
the atomic actions that we had before.
>> Interesting, okay,
so variable time steps.
>> Right.
>> So does that mess up everything?
>> It does,
because if you think about the way
Bellman works is it assumes a discount
that happens at every time step and
it accumulates
information along the way.
So we need to have a way
to capture all of that,
that allows us to get all of
the neat little features of an MDP,
while still allowing us to use
these variable time actions.
It turns out that's pretty
straightforward to do.
I'll just write out the equations for
you and hopefully, it'll be easy to see.